hey what's going on funny fat v BAM [ __ ]
feeling a little sore now a question
that I get asked a lot especially when
it comes to trying to lose weight you
know if you are overweight and that is
your goal is that we talk about a lot of
people who are naysayers and they doubt
you and it makes you feel bad for
instance there was a subscriber he asked
me to keep him anonymous but he told me
about a situation now in his situation
he's saying that he has tried losing
weight before he told his family he told
his friends but when it came down to it
he didn't really lose that much and so
this year he's trying again a people are
all like ah [ __ ] it you gonna stay fat
now I'm feeling that he's not the only
one out there that experiences this
because in all honesty is pretty common
now there are two ways that you could
think about this number one there's this
option where you're thinking okay well
[ __ ] these people these people are
poisonous in my life I need to cut them
out so I could work on myself and yeah
that is true if there are people in your
life that are gonna bring you down then
you should separate yourself from them
however I am NOT somebody who believes
that their actions won't produce
consequences it is also your
responsibility and you have to realize
that when you tell people the same story
over and over it's not really their
fault that they don't believe you people
also have to realize that whether it's
your new your goals or whatever you have
to stick to it and if you put that
information out there people are gonna
hold you to it you can't expect people
to expect greatness out of you but every
time you say you're gonna achieve
something you give it up immediately now
once again I'm not saying that you
didn't try I'm not saying you didn't put
the effort in but in all honesty you
[ __ ] lied to them me I did too I told
myself that I was gonna be in the NBA
look at me I'm in a room talking to
myself trying to help you [ __ ]
sometimes when you guys set your goals I
kind of want you guys to really embed
that in yourself first before you tell
other people I know that some of you
when you do that you're trying to like
create this sense of accountability but
in all honesty it's all gonna start with
you you could tell them you know a
million people out there that you're
gonna do this and that but if it doesn't
happen then it doesn't really mean
anything right like I could sit here and
waste in my stomach didn't look like a
crumpled up piece of news paper but
that's what happens I don't want y'all
to do something that I did my whole life
you know after I fractured both my
ankles and I couldn't play ball anymore
I kept on pointing my fingers at
everybody else
if that didn't happen I would be this if
this didn't happen I would be that it
doesn't [ __ ] matter it's not right
now I am NOT in the NBA I don't even
play ball well anymore and if anything I
even talked about getting mad and
[ __ ] people up I'm not gonna even do
that maybe me in the past but now I'm a
little [ __ ] I don't even understand
gang lingo anymore some dude yesterday
told me he was gonna pop up I was like
well let me get some of that soda too
then I need some hit friends y'all need
to let me in Yolo my [ __ ] so guess what
you have to do now all those times that
you I felt I knew what [ __ ] that not
even failed other people that you have
failed yourself and you fail to meet
your own expectations you got to shut
yourself the [ __ ] up now you have to
prove to yourself that this time around
you are going to do it you weren't going
to stick to it now for me yeah I lost 27
pounds I was supposed to lose about 60
or 7 it didn't happen I'm not hung up on
that I'm just telling myself that you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you didn't do it this is the year that
you're gonna do it and you're gonna keep
it off specifically because you know my
knees hurt every time I walk and every
time I do jumping jacks that claps on my
belly it's weird as [ __ ] it's like a
round of applause listen you got this
stop pointing at other people and
worrying about what other people are
saying about your journey just focus on
yourself I say this every time it is not
about the person you're gonna be
tomorrow it's the fact that you were
better than the person you were the day
before so I hope you take that advice in
[ __ ] all those other people stop being a
little [ __ ] and make [ __ ] happen
remember funny fat fit fam life is
always what you make it but it's up to
you to take what you deserve
let's go for broke
[Music]